in the ancient city of babylon tourists
are trickling back
that follows the iraqi government ending
the need for pre-arrival visa from
dozens of countries
this is a replica of babylon as it's
thought to have looked like in 600 bc
little is left of the original structure
but tourists are fascinated by 4 000
years of mesopotamia's cultural heritage
a lot of people back in ireland don't
even know that babylon is in iraq they
don't even know it's still a real place
you know so it's so incredible to be
able to come here
this is what remains of the hanging
gardens of babylon one of the seven
wonders of the ancient world
the original and renowned star gate was
shipped off to berlin by european
archaeologists at the beginning of the
last century
archaeologists say
numerous historical treasures are
waiting to be discovered across iraq
here in this area for instance
there are ancient ruins
beneath
these surrounding palm groves and
villages
they're threatened by oil pipelines
running through them
and encroachments by local residents
ur was the cultural heartland of ancient
mesopotamia
it's revered as the birth place of
prophet abraham
and gained international attention
following last year's visit by the head
of the catholic church pope francis
yeah and i think even more from my
parents they were quite nervous they
asked why are you going to iraq and
is it going to be safe um but the people
have been so friendly it's very
welcoming
so from my point of view it's a great
country to visit
thousands of priceless artifacts have
been looted or smuggled out of iraq
ancient temples palaces and tombs either
destroyed by isil or damaged under the
watch of consecutive
governments cultural tourism was
blooming before the 2003 us-led invasion
but we've recently received several
western excavation missions that have
helped a lot in discovering and
protecting many sites they've also
highlighted the importance of awe as a
center for interfaith and destination
for tourists from various backgrounds
a resurgence of tourism means creating
new development projects and job
opportunities for many here
these pieces are hand crafted by young
people who have no other jobs to do
so we count on the government to help
bring tourists back so that we can keep
the business afloat
and continue to maintain the immortal
memory of ancient mesopotamia
even though much of its magnificence has
been lost to decades of chaos and
neglect
al-jazeera
in babylon city
central iraq